tell us how serious was this glitch well
it's a very serious collision in the
sense that it affected all Delta's
flights worldwide and unlike the
Southwest situation which was mostly
domestic you're talking about an airline
that has you know global operations and
and planes that could be stranded all
over the world
Justin explain to us just how severe
this computer outage was was it purely
in operations or does it impact the
airplanes as well well it impacted
several Delta systems and they said that
it began with a power outage and it land
to their headquarters and we don't know
a lot of the details about what exactly
happened and how that interacted with
other systems but it definitely affected
the mobile apps the website the flight
operations and just a number of systems
that led to a really really tough tough
problem on a busy summer day yeah and
I'm sure it will impact customers will
people tend to not book Delta for some
time now is that why ed Bastian came out
with a video apology so shortly
afterwards
well I mean I don't think it's gonna
really dent Delta's business long-term
it's going to cause some short-term pain
in terms of passenger inconvenience and
people trying to get flights that you
know they may not be able to get on
another flight for a day or two or three
but long-term financially it's something
that Delta can easily easily handle
Justin how does something like this
happen you would imagine their backup
generator is I mean could there be more
is the story will people who start
getting suspicious if we don't get a lot
of transparency now from Delta yeah I
think people are probably a little bit
suspicious and exasperated because a
similar problem just last month at
Southwest cost four days of problems in
that airline you know had all hands on
deck trying to get the operation fixed
and that took over four days almost five
days and so I think if you're an airline
traveler now you're saying wait a minute
why don't these airlines have systems
that are more redundant so that we don't
see this kind of a crippling outage that
just affects flights everywhere you know
it's it's a little bit hard to believe
for people